It's the day of your daughter Milly's big football match,...
...and to be clear that is the sort of football you play with your feet.
Anyway, she is missing a vital piece of equipment.
Specifically, a size three Puma EvoPower Firm Ground soccer shoe, the left one.
And some of it, sadly, is in the family's three-year-old bulldog, Stuart.
Find your tablets and place an order with Amazon...
...for a pair of Puma Evopower Firm Ground soccer shoes...
...and have them delivered in 30 minutes or less.
And in a location not too far away,...
...a miracle of modern technology is dispatched.
It's an Amazon drone and after rising vertically like a helicopter...
...to nearly 400 feet,...
...this amazing hybrid design assumes a horizontal orientation...
...and becomes a streamlined and fast airplane.
This amazing innovation then lowers its sole slowly to the ground...
...drops off the package and flies straight back up to altitude.
And moments later you're walking through the door...
...with a brand new pair of Puma Evopower Firm Ground soccer shoes,...
...size three for Milly.
And a Nylabone chicken-flavored DuraChew for naughty, naughty Stuart.
And balance is restored to the universe.